to present today. I would ask the
owners of the building at 4547 Parkplace
that plan to build a mosque if this is
about multi-ultural
diversity.
Why is this a mosque and not a center,
which is what most of us would conceive
of as a multicultural
building
and endeavor
and I apologize to to any that are
offended by this, but this is the world
that we live in. And I am going to give
you quotes from the world we live in
that have been created by
people in in our midst.
First of all, I'd like to say I do
respect the mayor's position. It is as
it is indeed what we stand for as a free
nation. However, we must take the risk
to heir on the side of caution. Why is
there such a rush? We owe it.
We owe it to our descendants to proceed
with caution and deliberation.
We need to step back.
Look at the recent so-called religion of
peace Muslim demonstration in London
which has not been publicized in our own
newspapers.
Some
some of the messages on signs carried
read as the following and these are
direct quotes which I copied from the
signs themselves.
Freedom go to hell. Europe you will pay.
911 is on its way. Slay those who insult
Islam. Be prepared for the real
Holocaust.
Butcher those who mock Islam, behead
those who insult Islam, Islam will
dominate the world. I am reading, "It is
unsafe for a Westerner to go to London's
east side, and I do not want this to
happen at 4547 Park Place Avenue." Okay,
please consider the following
quote. The largest mosque in America
will I'm not a racist. Just
the largest mosque in America will be
used as a base to subvert the rest of
the United States. And this is by an
author of al-Qaeda reader Raymond
Ibrahim, expert on Islam. Ibrahim
informs us further that Ralph told
Arabic news publications in quotes, I do
not believe in religious dialogue and it
is clear an Islamic state can be
established in more than just a single
form or mold.
Way over the three minutes established,
bear with me please. It can be
established through a kingdom or a
democracy. The important issue is to
establish the general fundamentals of
Sharia that are required to govern. Does
this sound like a multicultural
proponent to you? Why aren't we
listening to experts who know the true
agenda of Imam Abdul Raf? Thank you.
We owe it to the American people and for
all that we stand for as a nation under
God with liberty and justice for all to
examine the thorough with thorough
deliberation all organizations and
monies supporting the endeavors of this
mosque. We must slow the process down
and give all issues and all facts the
respected, warranted, especially in the
light of the fact the plan is to
construct this Islamist base on the very
side of our own country's greatest
tragedy.
Thank you very much.
Let me let me obviously remind everyone
to keep to the three minutes. It's very
important. We have a lot of speakers and
I want everybody to have an opportunity
to be heard. So if if everyone would
abide by the threeminut rule that would
be helpful and Rachel Busan is next and
then Barbara Summer and then I'll call
five more names. Thank you.
Hello. My name is Rachel Busan. I'm a
community member.
Uh I only learned about today's hearing
this morning. Usually I'm articulate and
I would have something beautiful and
wonderful written out. So this is sort
of off the cuff. Sorry. Um,
I'm in favor of people in general
establishing buildings that are
meaningful to them. And that includes
places of worship.
Places of worship should be established
in conssonance and in harmony with the
overarching cultures, values, and laws.
The Cordoba Initiative's affection for
Sharia law is in no way conssonant with
American cultural and legal views and
values.
If anyone here thinks it is any leap to
make the claim that the Cordoba
initiative is working in favor of Sharia
law, I invite you to research the
organization's conference held in Koala
Lumpur and other sites on the internet.
And I invite you to look on
idealist.org. I have a copy here of a
job posting which I first received I
believe in late March for a job uh
Sharia Index project program associate.
Now when I got this job posting I'm a
social worker. I was extremely curious.
I had never heard of such a job. I went
to the website. I'd never heard of
Cordoba Initiative. At that time I found
that the majority of their paid staff
were working on this project. the Shara
project. I thought that's strange. The
area on the website at that time, the
website's now been changed. Shara index
took up this much space in their
website, but yet it was the majority of
their staff. Other projects that had no
staff committed to them, at least
according to their website, took up
pages.
I'll just put the question to the group.
You can you can think about this on your
own. What does that say? It seems to me
there's an obfiscation going on. There's
a concealment going on.
It's saying one thing and doing another.
So if you go to the website now, you'll
not see a list of staff who are working
on the Sharia project. There were three
or four of them at that time, full-time
people. You won't see that.
And why did they take that off? Because
as the furer has grown about this mosque
at ground zero, it seemed not opportune
to keep that in the public eye. It's
been scrubbed.
Now, the public face of Cordoba
initiative,
multicultural, multifaith center, that's
been put on the website now, too.
Don't believe it for a minute. Sharia
index project. They're reviewing all the
Islamic countries of the world to
appraise them in terms of their meeting
standards of Islamic governance. You can
read this on uh you can read this on
their website, but if anyone wants a
copy of this, I'll try to get it to you.
Thank you. Please submit it to the
record. Thank you very much. Appreciate
it.
Okay,
Barbara,
Barbara S. But Barbara, if you
Hi, good afternoon.
Barbara, you wait one moment start
please.
And I'll call five other people. Roxan,
can't read the name. Sorry, Roxan. The
last name De I'm not sure. Charles
Smith,
Seth Pomerance, and Joseph Richling. But
proceed.
I happened to witness some of what
happened on 911. I saw the smoke pouring
from the Twin Towers. Many of us saw the
horror and decimation of the area and
the horror of 911. I went to volunteer
on 911 at Beman Downtown Hospital that
night. The streets were covered with a
powder and the survivors were making an
exodus out of the area. In the Beakman
downtown hospital, the phones rang off
the hook. And it was the same question
over and over again. Where is my loved
one? Over and over and over again.
The problem was those people never many
of them never made it out. They were
burned alive from 911.
The testament to the survivors, all the
buildings that withtood the attack on
4547 Parkplace was right across the
street from 911. How can we eradicate
that memory
of all the loss and suffering that
happens on 911? Rather, why not
memorialize this event with a multimedia
research center about 911?
School children can be taught about that
day
and affected families can find comfort
that their loved ones will be remembered
throughout American history. Please
support landmark status.
Thank you very much.
Please proceed.
Identify yourself by name.
Hi, my name is Charles Smith and I'm a
New York City uh city resident. I'd like
to first thank you for letting us have
this open hearing. And I first would
like to say I'm not liberal. I'm not
conservative, Democrat, Republican. I
have friends from all backgrounds. I
have Muslim friends as well.
Uh
I and many others here oppose this not
only because we feel it should be deemed
a landmark because of the reasons that
Rick Lazio and Robert Spencer and others
have mentioned
but we have repeatedly asked and we
shouldn't even have to be at this point.
We've asked
Imam Faizel Abdul Rau to grant our
wishes, to honor us, to respect the fact
that this is very sensitive. It's a very
sensitive issue. It's very offensive to
us. And I continuously hear every day we
have to be respectful of the Muslims,
which I'm I'm fine with. But where is
that respect in turn? I ask.
There are plenty of places they could
put this mosque in New York City. Nobody
is saying I'm not saying
that the mosque should not be anywhere
in New York City. But why here? If you
do your research, people and I'm trying
to tell my American friends and people
that are not aware that in in mo the
Muslim world symbols are very very
they're taking very seriously. Example,
the the prophet of Muhammad, the cartoon
that they were, you know, making a joke
out of, what did they do? They took to
the streets, they rioted and they killed
50 people. That's how serious they take
this. And if you do your research,
anytime radical Muslims, let me clarify
so everybody understands, radical
Muslims, not all Muslims, anytime
they've conquered a land, they put that
mosque on that land is a sign of
victory.
Now, we need to educate yourselves on
the ideology of what's going on here.
And in addition to what Robert Spencer
said, I also found my own research from
former pal Palestinian liberation
organization terrorist Wed Shoubat who
said he found out on Arabic websites,
one of them being Alazer, that the imam
who is spearheading this contradicted
what he's saying. He's telling us this
is a place for open dialogue. But yet he
says something else on those websites
and I have those quotes right here if
anybody would like to see them.
Joe McCarthy.
Okay.
I have a list.
Have a respect, sir. We let you let you
speak. So I'm asking
speak.
The Jews are not innocent. The
Christians are not innocent. The Muslims
are not innocent. Everybody is fighting
everybody. Nobody. Everybody has blood
on their hands. When does this end? When
does it stop? And I ask one more thing
and I'll finish with this. Okay. The mo
good Muslims around the world, where are
you? If this is a religion of peace, how
come you're not speaking out? Is it
because you're afraid that you're going
to have a fatwa on your head? Or is it
because you sympathize with these
radicals?
Come out now.
Thank you, Roxan.
Roxan,
is there a Roxan, please? Roxan, you're
next. And then Seth Pomerance and Joseph
Richling. Thank you.
Hello. Um, I'm against the landmark
proposal because it doesn't uh designate
the merit. And also I just want to say
I'm so disappointed with such so so much
u racism in this place. So I have to go
now.
So
and for people who and and for people
who love America
please please let her complete her
testimony
and for people who love America they
really don't respect other people's
rights for free of expression and I'm
ashamed of the racism. It's
it's lots of hatred. It's my opinion.
Okay. my opinion
and I'm against I'm against the landmark
destination
testimony
for the record I am against the landmark
destination and I'm just very
disappointed with the race system in
this place so thank you
thank you
we really need to hear the testimony the
people who were in that row near the mic
so please refrain from the comments or
get up and testify yourselves
but
Seth Pomerance will be Next,
Seth Pomeran's here.
Hi.
Okay.
My name is Seth Pomerance. I've been
associated with this building for a very
long time.
Shut up.
Um, I first want to apologize to the
commission for involving everyone in a
religious and social debate. Otherwise,
uh, even though you are more of a, uh,
city agency.
Uh my main argument against landmarking
it would be the fact that all the
surrounding building uh buildings are in
the style of office buildings. Even 50
Murray the building behind it was a
converted office to rental. The building
next to it at 53 Parkplace
was a school which was also turned into
a rental. The building across from it is
100 church, which is a current office
building. So, it's kind of weird to have
this little tiny thing in the middle of
a block when you could actually do
something with it. Thank you.
Thank you very much,
Joseph Richling. Is Joseph Richling
here?
Okay, I'm going to call some more names,
please. Is that Jo Joseph Rling?
Please.
Hello. My name is Joseph Reichling. I
listen to everybody here. I um I'm 54
years old. I have two grandchildren. My
son works for sanitation. Was down at
and I am American.
[Applause]
There's a girl over here with the
American flag. I usually have a do-agg
of the American flag, but I read about
it in the AM because I had an
appointment in Manhattan today. I listen
to everybody. I agree somewhat with the
uh the person I was be with the the
radical. Yes, there are radicals. There
are some good Muslims. I believe in that
freedom of speech, but at what price?
Not too much freedom. Um,
my son,
I had lost people down in 911 like
everybody else. Jennifer Mazada, Frankie
Cosner. So, my son had just started
working for sanitation three weeks
before. I says to him, "Are you going to
go down there and do your part?" He
says, "Yeah." He goes down, he comes
back and I says, "Joe," he goes to
sleep. He did a double. I says, "Joe,
are you going to go back down there?" He
says, "No." I says, "Why not?" He says,
"Dad, you didn't see what I saw." I
backed off. I just want to say that it
is a historical site. And yes, that the
uh the piece of the plane went into the
uh to the building and that should
definitely clarify it as a historical
site. I do not believe that there should
be a Muslim uh religious uh center there
at all. There should definitely not be
because I mean have we forgotten? Is our
forefathers turning over their grave?
What do we stand for? What what is it?
Have we forgotten? What happened at 911?
Gee, unbelievable.
Everybody underneath, we can't forget.
We must not forget 911. And God bless
America all the way.
Thank you. Call some more names now.
Roselene Kalen,
Sally Regan,
and Natasha Rivera,
and Scott Kurthers. Please.
Good afternoon. My name is Rosene Talon
and I lost my only sibling, Shawn. Um,
he was a firefighter down at the World
Trade Center firehouse, ladder 10.
And I wish I was here today just to talk
about a building because my husband's
project executive in a restoration
construction firm in the city. And I
wish I was here just to talk about the
building because if it was just for the
building, I'm a historical
um building buff. I I'm one of those
people that says, "I wish they weren't
taking down that old building and
putting up a glass structure with no
character. I wish I was only here to
talk about that and that I was here to
express just that feeling.
But I'm here as a testament to the life
and death of my brother.
And I'm here for the safety of my
children and for the safety of our city.
And I was never against Muslim people
before 911 and I'm not against them now.
As a matter of fact, one of my
co-workers when I was teaching was a
Muslim girl. Of all the people in the
school I taught, she and I had the most
in common on 911 because we were both
affected.
And I'll never forget her. So it is not
an anti-Muslim sentiment that I harbor.
It is a self-preservation,
a protective a natural instinct. And I I
would think that Muslim people who live
in the city too should feel the way I
feel that we don't want another 9/11
down at ground zero. We don't want
anything that has to do with terror,
fear, fright. We want peace. We want to
be able to go down there and remember
those who died. And
I I know there are Muslims in this
auditorium and I want to express to them
this is not an a 9/11 family member
who's angry at all Muslims. I am a
mother. I'm a sister. I'm a daughter who
just wants a safe city. And I want to
feel like I felt before 911 that
this might not happen again. And all I
want I would right now talk to all the
politicians and say, you know, you're in
charge of this city and you're in charge
of our safety and I want you to make
sure that the money that is being used
is coming from all legitimate sources.
And you know, if the IRS wanted to audit
it me as an American in the morning, in
a heartbeat, I'd have to open all my
books. That's right. So it is not
unamerican
to ask imam the imam in charge of this
mosque to open his books.
So Mayor Bloomberg that's not
unamerican.
It's very American.
And we're I hope you I hope you and I'm
not racist. Thank you.
No I'm not. You're you're saying that so
that it makes it sound like I'm racist.
And I could not be more further from the
truth. Let her continue. I apologize.
I apologize to Dave's up there. We need
to get the police to quiet this person.
We need to have freedom of speech. I'm
asking for the police to quiet this man.
Please, everyone should be quiet so you
can continue your remarks. Are you
concluding?
In a minute, you're going to have to
remove yourself from the from the
audience because we're not able to
conduct the hearing. So, please, ma'am,
in conclusion,
in conclusion, thank you.
Thank you. In conclusion, I just ask
very respectfully from all of us to make
sure that we do the right thing down at
ground zero as we've always promised to
never forget.
Thank you very much, Sally. Hard
yelling. It gets out of control.
He is out of control.
Sally witch hunt.
Regan right witch hunt.
Sally Reanhard is
I can't speak until this man is quieted.
And I'm asking you to get the police and
to quiet this person. This is America. I
have the right to speak. Please, you
have to you have to refrain from if you
want to speak, you can testify.
All right. I'm told this is a
professional heckler who who who goes
around to every one of these meetings.
Oh, how dare I go to that?
Okay.
You're right about that,
Sally. Please excuse me. Excuse me. Why
don't you go outside if you want to
continue the dialogue out there as you
what whatever you're doing and then we
want to continue the hearing because
there's a lot of testimony that is
informative and interesting and we would
like you to continue with respect from
the audience. Please go ahead.
Thank you. My name is Sally Reaganhard.
I'm not here to represent any business,
any industry, any real estate. I'm here
to represent my son,
probationary firefighter Christian
Reaganhard, who lost his life along with
343 firefighters at the World Trade
Center on 911.
My son was a loving person, a graduate
of the Bronx High School of Science,
146 IQ, a beautiful liberal person who
loved all people, races, colors, and
creeds. He lived a life of peace and
understanding.
Yet, he was murdered on 911
along with 3,000 people.
I'm here today primarily to ask your
board to follow your integrity in this
matter. Follow what you have studied in
your life. Follow the science, follow
the art, follow the guidelines
regarding making this building a a
landmark building. Please do not fold to
the political forces, to political
correctness, to politicians that want to
get reelected and that want to go
further up in the pecking order. How
dare they
impose their muscle on a group of people
who I'm sure you only have the best and
the highest integrity for this city to
preserve the remnants of a city that is
being systematically destroyed by
buildings
and throwing away the history of this
city. So that's why I'm here. I want to
say something else since other people
have mentioned other things.
This is a very very difficult situation
but I would ask that people look back in
history for a precedent for not turning
this building into a mosque. And that
precedent occurred in Germany in Oswitch
in the late 80s. A group of Catholic
nuns built a convent right outside of
the Jewish concentration camp where
Jewish people were massacred
in Germany. It it affected the Jewish
people so greatly that there was great
despair and there was a very very bad
aura between Christians and Jews. Pope
John Paul II intervened and in
acquiescence and understanding for the
suffering of Jewish people even though
Catholic nuns were never never
implicated in the Holocaust.
Nevertheless, in a sense of
understanding and love and honor, he
closed the convent. If the pope of the
Catholic Church can close the Catholic
convent, then all of these officials can
say no. The mosque is inappropriate for
the suffering and the sensitivities of
the 9/11 families. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Okay. Natasha Rivera
and Natasha Rivera and Scott Kurthers.
Good afternoon. My name is Scott
Kurthers. I am a uh service disabled
veteran. Served honorably in the United
States military for 10 years. I'm a New
York State EMT, National Registry EMT,
and I responded to the World Trade
Center on September 11th in my capacity
with regional EMS.
I thought this was going to be basically
about uh historical significance. I
didn't realize it was going to be
we were going to be able to have other
types of conversations. So, I I'll go
with this first. According to the
commission's website, the word landmark
is defined as a structure at least 30
years old and possessed of a special
character or a special historical or
aesthetic interest or value as part of
the development, heritage or c cultural
characteristics of the city, state, or
the nation. That's it's your website.
Certainly, the fact that the worst
terrorist attack in the history of our
nation directly impacted the structure
in question went on September 11th
landing gear of one of the flights,
which has all been said before, but it's
what I wrote, so I'm going to read it.
carrying more than 100 people to their
death and causing the murder of
thousands more. Crash through the roof
makes this structure of historical
significance not just to this city but
to the country as a whole. Indeed, to
the rest of the free world, fighting the
cancer of religious extremism.
Having just returned from Europe and
having had the pleasure to visit a great
many historical locations, many of which
have little if any aesthetic value, in
fact, many were little more than ruins,
I must remind the learned ladies and
gentlemen of this commission that they
are the guardians of our history.
Please do not deprive our
grandchildren's grandchildren the
opportunity to visit where our where
their country's history was made.
So that's what I wrote and I came here
and I heard all this other stuff. So uh
I made some notes. Certainly I echo the
concept if it's if it's multicultural
then it's not a mosque. It's a
multicultural center. So don't call it a
mosque. Call it a multicultural center.
Uh it was considered some 20 odd years
for aesthetic reasons and I've seen the
building. It's really not all that
attractive. So, I could see where you
might not grant it landmark status on
that matter, but since it was involved
in September 11th, there can be no
debate of its historical significance
since
since no other building was affected in
such a manner. So, there there can be no
debate about that. I um I'd like I'd
like to to ask you how you think that
Private Smith would feel when he opens
up the stars and stripes in Afghanistan
next week, next month, next year, and
finds out that this committee and the
mayor and all the other individuals
involved have granted um have granted
these folks permission
to build this mosque. So when Private
Smith comes home and he goes and he
visits the uh the World Trade Center
site because he's watched people, men
and women die around him in the in the
in the endeavor to preserve the freedom
of this country. And he's standing there
looking at that site and he turns
around, he sees the mosque,
looks at the site, looks the mosque. You
really kind of have to ask himself what
what it's all about.
I I need you also to know that I stand
before you as a dead man.
I responded to the Rod Trade Center and
I have lost some 40% of my lung
capacity. I was murdered that day. I
just haven't died yet.
Please,
please help me teach my children that
the character of this country remains
intact while we're on
day 90.
Please, please try to ignore him and and
continue your testimony and wind it up
if you would. Please. I I would
[Applause]
[Music]
out the door. That's good. Please
continue.
Yes, sir.
Sorry, Mr. Kathers.
Okay,
continue.
on uh on the 90th some odd day of
thousands of gallons of oil being pumped
into the ocean and and everpresent
political corruption and uh
difficulties. I I don't know what to
tell my kids. I mean, I I don't know
what to tell them. I don't want to bring
them to the World Trade Center site and
and have them turn around and see that
mosque. I'm begging you to do what you
know is right.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank
you, Jan. Now, I'm going to call a few
more names. Janet Casio, Jay Townsend,
and Rafi Cathwari,
are they here?
And then call a couple more. Pat Mian
and Mark Amaruso.
So, who do we have at the mic?
No one. Or here comes someone, please.
Towns in here.
Uh I am going to ask that you today uh
make this building a landmark status
building for the same reasons that
others have spoken here today. I spoke
against the construction of this mosque
at ground zero at a rally about a month
ago in lower Manhattan. I am here again
today as a candidate for the United
States Senate and to date the only one
of seven who has been willing to take a
position on this issue.
Because of my opposition to this, I had
been called the same terms and the same
names that many others in this room have
been called. We are not religious bigots
because we oppose this. We
We are intolerant of the intolerance
that was on display that day.
intolerant of the violence done to 3,000
freedom loving people who lost their
lives that day.
I also want to speak on behalf of the
majority of New Yorkers who oppose the
location of this mosque. I am a longtime
New Yorker. I have been all over the
world. I can tell you this. New York
City and its people are the most
tolerant people in the world. And this
is not about intolerance.
There are plenty of places in New York
City to build a mosque. I simply ask
today, not there and not now. Thank you
very much. Thank you. Thank you.
Please. Next. Thank you very much. Next.